[Music]
happy Friday and welcome back to
certified country I'm Sophia Lacy and
it's only February but I say it is never
too soon to start planning for summer
especially when it comes to all of the
huge tours that we have to look forward
to
we've got Keith Urban Miranda Lambert
Luke Bryan and so many more and I'm
going to break it all down for you here
but first I have a special treat for you
[Music]
[Music]
miron loris is opening for Niall Horan
on his Flickr North American tour and
I've got a pair of tickets and sound
check passes to give to one lucky winner
I'm gonna fill you in on how you can
have a chance to win at the end of the
show so sit tight first let's get into
some other shows that you might want to
check out this summer
starting with Little Big Town and
Miranda Lambert
[Music]
they're co-headlining the 13 date
bandwagon tour kicking off July 12th in
Charlotte North Carolina Luke Bryan is
going XL stadium-sized for his what
makes you country tour bringing along
Sam hunt and John party along with
Morgan Wallen and Carly Pearce Lucas set
to hit the iconic Wrigley Field Dodger
Stadium Fenway Park Heinz Field MetLife
Stadium and several more this summer and
if I know Luke those shows are going to
be absolutely epic meanwhile Keith Urban
is back with a new album and World Tour
graffiti you
[Music]
so
he also just so happens to be bringing
out my girl Kelsea Ballerini with him
[Music]
honestly I've seen them both live and
they put on such an unforgettable show
you guys this is going to be so so good
I promise now actually if you're north
of the border keith has chosen Calgary
native Lindsey l to join him for the
Canadian leg of his tour and I could not
be more excited for Lindsey you guys
this is so huge for her in fact we have
a very special interview with Lindsey
coming up right here on certified
country in a few weeks so please stay
tuned for that
[Music]
all right now you know I didn't forget
about my buddy Blake Shelton his country
music freak store kicked off last night
in Tulsa with Brett Eldredge karlie
Pierce and Trace Adkins that show runs
for about another month so it's not
technically a summer show but I know how
much y'all love Blake and I am sure that
you've already got your tickets to check
out his show and while we're on the
subject of spring we might as well get
into stagecoach here for a minute the
country music festival is set for the
weekend of April 27th in Indio
California with three days and nights of
performances Florida Georgia line Keith
Urban and Garth Brooks are headlining
then mark your calendars for May 5th
because that is when the I heart country
festival by AT&T will take over Austin
Texas with performances from Keith Luke
Dustin Cole Sugarland Marin and more
those tickets go on sale next month now
it is time for the moment of truth I've
got two tickets and soundcheck passes
for Niall Horan's flicker tour with
Maren Morris in the u.s. city of your
choice here's what you need to do for
your chance to win visit ET online.com
slash giveaways to see a complete list
of rules and officially enter by
midnight Friday February 23rd that's the
key you guys you need to go to ET
online.com
for a chance to win alright and hit the
comments below to tell me why you want
to see Niall and Marin live Plus go
ahead and tag a friend you'll bring with
you hint hint if you both enter it'll
double your chances but if the Flickr
tour isn't for you comment and let me
know which shows you're most looking
forward to seeing this summer come back
and see us again next Friday for a brand
new episode of certified country with a
very special guest we'll see you then
you